est-ce que vous pensez que cette
contestation allumée il y a quelques
mois sur la réforme de retraite va
s'éteindre
oui je pense qu'ils ont ils ont perdu
ils ont perdu le combat législatif ils
ont ils ont pas tout à fait perdus parce
qu'ils ont réussi à discréditer
l'Assemblée nationale mais ça passe
seulement pour cette loi depuis 9 mois
il a transforme quand je disais en une
ZAD une zone à délirée d'ailleurs à mon
avis mais sur ce thème là ils ont perdu
je pense là aussi quand je vais quand je
rentre chez moi le week-end et que je
discute avec
avec les gens de mon département je
pense que la situation n'est pas la même
que l'été il y a un mois ou deux le vote
a eu lieu ou le vote n'a pas eu lieu
comme vous voudrez mais en fin de 43 a
eu lieu et la motion de censure a eu
lieu parce que quand vous dites il y a
pas de vote il y a quand même une notion
de censure qui a été déposée et qui a
pas été votée c'est un vote ça et
aujourd'hui je pense que les gens je
crois les gens que je vois pas tous bien
entendu il y en a qui continuent à être
extrêmement contre mais se disent et je
crois que les gens ont compris à travers
c'est peut-être une des forces de ce
débat qui a eu lieu beaucoup dans les
médias tout le monde a compris que le
système est ne pouvait pas continuer
qu'il était déficitaire alors on n'est
pas content de la solution certains ne
sont pas contents mais je pense que les
gens sans doute envolent au gouvernement
mais se disent maintenant ça y est le
c'est joué passons à autre chose
[Musique]